if you're like me you hustle down to
your local Cinema to see the scariest
film about a killer bear since that
Winnie the Pooh horror movie
bruh for the life of me I don't know why
the tagline wasn't you'll poo your pants
for those of you familiar with my
channel you'll know I do a lot of ending
explains but I thought for this one we'd
look at the actual true story the film
is based on and what parts of the film
are real obviously this part and what
isn't and don't worry if you haven't
seen the movie there will be no Major
Spoilers but before we get into it make
sure to like And subscribe so I can
support my newfound cocaine addiction I
was shocked when Elizabeth Banks you
might remember as Effie Trinket in The
Hunger Games was set to direct a movie
with a working title cocaine bear this
wasn't supposed to be the name but
producers couldn't come up with anything
else and the Public's response was crazy
positive so kept it they did the film
itself is Loosely based off a book
called the Bluegrass Conspiracy which
outlines the various doings of cartels
in Kentucky from the late 70s to early
80s one such event revolving around at
cocaine loving bear in the movie we see
the event that sparked this insane story
a corrupt Kentucky cop turned drug
Smuggler by the name of Andrew Thornton
it's hard to tell in the film but he's
played by the Americans Alum Matthew
Reese he was on his way back from
Colombia when a call on the radio
informed him federal agents were hot on
his Trail he turned his Cessna 404 on
autopilot and escaped what the movie
doesn't tell you is that there were
actually two people on board not much is
known about this mystery partner but
unlike Thornton it's believed this guy
made it out alive as no one else was
found in Hayesville North Carolina where
the crashed plane was discovered
Thornton's body was discovered
splattered across a Knoxville Tennessee
residence driveway where it's believed
his parachute got caught While others
believed the sheer weight of what
Thornton was carrying may have
contributed to the failure and this guy
was carrying a lot his body was found
with 75 pounds of cocaine valued at 15
million dollars a bulletproof vest night
vision goggles 31 grams of gold firearms
and knives let's not forget his Gucci
loafers covered in blood and guts in the
movie the Death is more so contribute to
him hitting his head on the way out of
the plane what follows is a series of
characters all converging on
Chattahoochee National Park where all
this cocaine allegedly landed fun fact
the film was actually shot in Ireland
and in post-production the CGI bear they
used was called koki so the character
with the most at stake is drug dealer
Sid played by Ray Liotta who tragically
passed away in May of last year in fact
it was one week after he finished
re-recording his lines in
post-production that he died we have
Henry and his love interest Dede who
stumble upon some cocaine and actually
try some but don't worry this didn't
happen in real life in fact every
character besides the drug dealer that
fell out of the plane is completely made
up and as much as I'd like to say
cocaine bear went on a Coke field
Rampage I'm afraid the real story is far
more tragic three months after the
Downing of the coke plane a dead bear
was found by the Georgia Bureau of
Investigation having ingested 34 kilos
or around 2 million dollars worth of
cocaine according to the medical exam
examiner the bear likely died from a
combination of cerebral hemorrhaging
respiratory failure hyperthermia renal
failure heart failure and stroke so
basically everything my body went
through in college if this story
couldn't get any stranger cocaine bear
lives on you can see the real cocaine
bear on display at the Kentucky fun Mall
in Lexington Kentucky where it's been
given the pseudonym Pablo Escobar I hope
you enjoyed this cocaine fueled video be
sure to give it a like and comment on
what you thought about cocaine bear
below thanks for watching for more bad
takes you can follow me on Twitter and
Instagram at thinkstory YT until next
time remember bear get cocaine
foreign
[Music]